have you ever wondered how much chat GPT
engineers make well the answer is 925
thousand dollars and that's not top
earners or directors or Executives that
is straight up the median the average
Joe at open AI is paid 300 000 in cash
and 625 000 in stock every single year
forget making 300 a day using chat GPT
you might as well make a million dollars
making chat GPT of course you would
first have to become an experienced
decoder but it's clearly worth the
investment but is it actually worth it
for openai the parent of chat GPT I mean
just think about it even if openai were
to employ just a thousand Engineers
we're talking about annual payroll of a
billion dollars if they were to grow to
the scale of Google we'd be talking
about nearly 200 000 employees or nearly
200 billion dollars in payroll every
single year of course not all of them
would be Engineers but you get the idea
it's expensive as hell and that's just
half the puzzle to develop something
like chat GPT you not only need the
smartest human brains on the planet but
you also need a smartest computer brains
on the planet 30 000 of them to be
precise each of these bad boys comes in
at 10 to 15 G's so we're talking about
300 million dollars at the very least
and who knows how long they have until
these gpus become outdated not to
mention all of the servers databases and
infrastructure required to support their
massive operation thankfully they have
hundreds of millions of users paying the
wait a minute it's free yeah I don't
think you'd be surprised to hear that
they lost approximately 540 million
dollars last year and chat GPT didn't
even come out till December so their
losses this year are only going to be
exponentially worse almost definitely
gonna be in the billions and with how
early this technology is you can bet
that losses will only get worse as open
AI doubles triples quadruples down on r
d of course if they're able to climb
this mountain they literally have it
trillions waiting for them on the other
side but to get there they're first
gonna have to spend hundreds of billions
themselves which brings us into the
question of the day can open AI actually
afford to see the finish line
foreign
Ty will actually be a viable Endeavor
we'll first have to take a look at how
chat gbd plans on making money they
could of course want ads like Google and
they may very well do this at one point
but this doesn't seem to be their main
monetization strategy at least not right
now it seems like they far prefer more
direct Avenues of Revenue like Pro
subscriptions they currently offer a Pro
Plan that costs 20 per month it comes
with a better availability faster
responses and early access to new
features honestly this isn't all that
valuable to the Casual user right now
but I think it's safe to assume that the
disparity between the free plan and the
Pro Plan will only grow with time making
it much more appealing if they're
eventually able to get 200 or 300
million people to sign up for this that
would pull in 50 to 70 billion dollars
per year which is phenomenal but that's
not where the real money is the real
money is with other companies you see it
open aisl's API access to chat GPT this
essentially means that you can make
requests to check GPT using Code
allowing you to integrate charge GPT
into any app or website you're building
the pricing for these requests are based
on tokens 1000 tokens is approximately
750 words for every 750 words worth of
input you have to pay them 3 cents and
for every 750 words worth of output you
have to pay them 6 cents that's if you
want 8K worth of context if you want 32k
worth of context the price doubles that
might sound cheap and it is if you're
making hundreds or even thousands of
requests but when you really start
looking at Large Scale integration it
becomes a very expensive it very quickly
let's consider a real world example Bing
now Microsoft owns about half of openai
so I'm sure they get highly subsidized
pricing for Bing but let's assume that
they don't just to illustrate how
expensive Tech GPT really is it's
estimated that for every 100 000
requests into gpd4 with an 8K context
window the API costs 7 500 Bing gets
over 900 million searches every single
day which translates to 67.5 million
dollars over a year we're talking about
a just under 25 billion dollars and
that's just from Bing imagine if Google
integrated gpt4 every day they get 8.5
billion searches so they'd have to pay
openai over 600 million dollars every
day or 230 billion dollars every year of
course that would be unsustainable for
Google and there's no way they'll be
paying those prices but I think you can
see how big companies could easily end
up paying billions if not tens of
billions to open AI every single year
for large-scale integration if you get a
few hundred of these big boys on your
side like Oracle or AWS or sap have
managed to do you'd be pulling in
hundreds of Blends per year or even
trillions so theoretically speaking not
only does openai have a viable business
model but a super lucrative one there's
just one Teensy tiny problem though
getting these companies on board is not
only hard but extremely expensive
foreign
for one many of the biggest companies in
the world will try to directly compete
with the chat GPT Google is already
doing it with a board and even meta is
trying to create their own language
model so you can bet that these
companies won't be adopting open AI
Solutions anytime soon fortunately there
are still plenty of large companies out
there that aren't creating their own
language model but could very much
benefit from one likely the best example
is Apple in the most recent WWDC they
didn't even mention the term AI much
less an AI language model now they could
very well be working on a Model behind
the scenes for Siri but I think they're
taking a different approach just a few
weeks ago Tim Cook said that he likes
chat GPT and that he uses it personally
but just a few weeks before that Apple
actually banned chat GPT internally
you're probably wondering why apple is
sending these mixed signals well they're
basically saying we like chat gbt and
may even be willing to integrate it but
only for the right price and when I say
right price I don't mean cheap or or
even free calls to touch EBT I mean chat
GPT pays Apple for them to use it this
probably makes no sense why in the world
would Chachi PT pay for Apple to use
chat GPT well the same reason that
Google does you know how Siri and Safari
automatically redirect you to Google
search well this isn't just because
Google is Tim's preferred search engine
or something it's because Google hands
over Apple a casual 20 billion per year
and that's just to get apple to stay out
of the search space imagine how much
Apple would want to stay out of the
language model space safe to say more
than 20 billion per year over the long
term now openai could just avoid doing
business with companies like apple but
you can bet that if openai doesn't make
a deal with Apple Google will they
already have a deal with Apple and
they're paying them an extra 20 or 30
billion every year to integrate the
board into Siri and Safari is a
no-brainer that literally makes bar the
default AI for over a billion people
basically overnight if you monetize
these users well that'll produce way
more than the 20 or 30 billion they have
to pay Apple but getting to that point
does take time during which Google will
have to continue paying Apple again for
Google the trillion dollar giant that's
no problem but for openai we're talking
about their entire valuation being
handed over to Apple every single year
and that's just half the equation you
can bet that someone like apple won't be
willing to deal with error messages like
these if they are going to push your
product to their billion users they're
gonna first want assurance that you can
handle that sort of load fortunately we
already know how to handle these loads
it's just really really expensive Google
regularly spends 30 billion dollars just
upgrading infrastructure openai would
have to build it from scratch or rent it
from someone like Google or Amazon which
will only be more expensive so not only
will open AI have to spend tens of
billions on customer acquisition but
they'll also have to spend tens of
billions on supporting these customers
at their insane scale at that rate
Microsoft's massive 10 billion meant
wouldn't even last a couple of months I
think you can start to see the problem
everything we've discussed so far is
simply the cost to acquire and maintain
customers but with a product like
chatgpt r d is even more important all
of these deals and Partnerships only
work if you continuously have a market
leading product and let's just say the
competition is by no means holding back
I mean just think about this our boy
Mark is willing to spend a hundred
billion dollars on VR how much do you
think he's willing to spend on AI oh
wait we have an official number it's 33
billion dollars this year alone again
that's more than the entire market cap
of open AI now just because you spend
more money it doesn't mean that you'll
come out ahead but then again it often
does the bottom line is that the AI game
is simply being played on a different
magnitude traditional startups need
hundreds of millions of dollars open AI
needs hundreds of billions of dollars
and that's not my opinion Sam Altman the
CEO of openai himself has suggested that
they'll need 100 billion dollars in the
coming years itself so in the next
decade or so we're looking at 300 or 500
billion or some crazy number like that
and the obvious reality is that there is
absolutely no way that they'll be able
to afford these numbers by themselves
anytime soon I mean the company
literally pulled in a whopping 28
million last year this is expected to go
to 40 billion by the end of this decade
but in the context of a multi 100
billion dollar investment that's still
not all that great in fact it's probably
not even enough to achieve profitability
so open AI is by no means a sustainable
business by any stretch of the
imagination the only way that open AI
works is by getting a bunch of people to
invest hundreds of billions maybe even
nearly a trillion dollars in the hopes
of making tens of trillions even the
richest VCS and hedge funds can't afford
this there's only two groups of people
who can afford this the first is
governments but they're still stuck on
Internet Explorer so they're out of the
question the other is Big tech companies
open AI realized this four years ago
that's why they stopped being a
non-profit and partnered with Microsoft
and let me just say partnering with
Microsoft was a brilliant decision
partnering with Google wouldn't have
been nearly as effective because Google
wouldn't have been in any rush they
wouldn't feel threatened so they could
just go at whatever Pace they wanted but
Microsoft on the other hand was thirsty
for market share Bing and the edge had
been getting destroyed by Google for
years so AI was Microsoft's big shot at
taking back the lead and they ate up
open AI at the same time openai was also
able to provoke Google and start the
biggest Tech War since like iOS vs
Android and now they suddenly have the
full financial support and attention of
a 2.5 trillion dollar company so the
answer is no openai cannot afford to
survive with their million dollar
salaries and 28 million dollars in
Revenue but don't worry they're not
going anywhere because they've found a
sugar daddy that's gonna make sure that
they get to the Finish Line somehow
Microsoft has become Google's biggest
competitor but they're also not scared
to partner with Google either if you
want to learn about how Microsoft became
the most humble tech company check out
this video but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next one